das wird alles verändern diese batterie
hat unfassbare leistungsdaten zehnmal
höhere energiedichte in 15 minuten von
20 auf 80 prozent geladen und dazu
sicherer stabiler und langlebiger ein us
kanadische startup unternehmen hat
lithium ionen akkus so umkonstruiert
dass deren lebensdauer und energiedichte
wesentlich erhöht wird davon könnten vor
allem e autos profitieren zwar sollen
das erste produkte schon dieses jahr
geben allerdings werden elektroautos
damit erst später ausgerüstet aber so
lang ist es da auch nicht mehr
also das ist wirklich der absolute
hammer kriegs und science fiction gibt
es täglich spannende science wie das
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen immer wieder
berichten wir hier bei pixum science
fiction über neue technologien die uns
endlich den langersehnten super akku
bescheren könnten regelmäßig gibt es
neue erfolge in diesem bereich aber
meistens sind das forschungsergebnisse
bei denen es noch ziemlich lange dauern
kann bis wir sie in den händen halten
jetzt soll das anders werden die
fachleute eines us kanadischen startups
nutzen sogenannte wafer aus der
halbleiterproduktion das seien etwa ein
millimeter dicke scheiben die als
grundplatte dienen auf der dann
elektronische bauelemente chips
hergestellt werden in der
halbleiterindustrie kommen diese wafer
schon seit einiger zeit zum einsatz ohne
großen aufwand können diese für die neue
akku technologie mit dem namen power
chip genutzt werden heißt also im
klartext das ganze basiert nicht auf
einer neuen erfindung sondern auf einer
technologie die bereits seit längerer
zeit erfolgreich genutzt wird dazu der
ceo von ex energy christie co
wir unternehmen bewährte schritte zur
herstellung von chips und wenden sie auf
diese batterie an wir nehmen etwas aus
einer branche und wenden es auf eine
andere branche an wie er findet an
dieser freundliches neues wir können die
welt verkaufen so dass wir nicht in eine
eigene fabrik investieren müssen
der vorteil für die neu entwickelte
technologie können sogar veraltete und
dicke wafer genutzt werden die
anderweitig nicht mehr gebraucht werden
das us kanadische startup versieht diese
gewöhnlichen 12 zoll wafer mit bis zu
160 millionen mikroskopisch kleinen
löchern so produzieren sie strukturen
die an waffeln erinnern die
gesamtoberfläche der batterien
wird im vergleich zu einer
zweidimensionalen oberfläche somit um
das bis zu 70 fache erhöht wichtig
hierbei jedes dieser kleinen löcher ist
praktisch eine sehr kleine batterie wenn
ein einzelner fehler auftritt breitet
sich der fehler nicht aus diese
architektur macht die batterie absolut
sicher denn durchbrennen und explosionen
werden vermieden
an der einen seite des wetters wurde
eine leitende beschichtung angebracht
und die andere seite wurde mit einer
nicht leitenden beschichtung versehen
die neu entwickelte technologie kommt an
den noten der lithium ionen batterien
zum einsatz denn hier sammeln sich alle
elektronen wenn die batterien voll
geladen sind die neu entwickelten an
noten des start ups haben also eine
löchrige und dreidimensionale oberfläche
ganz im gegensatz zu den gewöhnlichen
anoden laut der erfinderinnen und
erfinder wird so eine energiedichte
möglich die zehnmal höher liegt als bei
bisherigen akkutechnologie doch die
größere oberfläche soll außerdem auch zu
einer deutlich gestiegenen
ladegeschwindigkeit führen nach angaben
der firma soll das akku von 20 auf 80
prozent in 15 minuten aufgeladen werden
können und das ist ja der ladebereich in
dem akustisch am besten befinden sollen
um lange zu halten und auch schnell
geladen werden zu können und nicht nur
das den unternehmensangaben zufolge
könnte so auch die lebensdauer der
batterien um das fünf bis zehnfache
erhöht werden denn so genannte dendriten
also elektrochemische ablagerungen an
den elektroden eines akkus sorgen
normalerweise für einen schnellen
verschleiß diese spitzen nadel artigen
strukturen wachsen mit der zeit und
stören so die funktion der akkus und
können zu gefährlichen kurzschlüssen
führen doch die neu entwickelte an ote
widersteht der dendriten bildung
aufgrund ihrer nicht leitenden
beschichtung auf dem silizium wafer als
weiteren vorteil preis das start-up
seinen neuen lithium ionen akkus als
sicherer als die bisherigen akkus an und
schon bald sollen wäre das auch in der
praxis zu sehen bekommen dazu ex energy
wir gehen davon aus dass unsere
batterien bereits 2020 im mobilitäts
produkten wie motorrädern rolland
drohnen robotern und viele mehr zum
einsatz kommen werden bei
elektrofahrzeugen wird es wahrscheinlich
2022 oder 2023 in allerdings erst einmal
begrenztem umfang wow das ist wirklich
wirklich sensationell übrigens hat es
sich nicht um irgendein startup mit
vielleicht unseriösen publikationen
bekannte unternehmen wie beispielsweise
motorola und intel haben
mehr als 80 millionen us-dollar
investiert auch das us
energieministerium hat sich mit
fördermitteln beteiligt also absolut
legend würde ich mal sagen dieses
elektroauto hier verbraucht keine
energie anklicken anschauen wenn ihr
mehr zu diesen themen erfahren wollt
klicks um nature unbedingt abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran